hi this is jonathan rotz field
agronomist with pioneer today i want to
talk with you a little bit about cover
crops
now it's early spring and that means
we're all getting ready for another
great year another great growing season
and one of the things that we think
about this time of year is preparing
that field whether that be tillage or
for a lot of my guys that are no-till
it's thinking about cover crops in this
field we have some really nice growth on
our cover crops and some might think
about terminating but actually a fair
amount of folks are learning that maybe
this isn't the best thing to do now most
of us understand the benefits of cover
crops soil conservation is a huge thing
we've had this field covered all winter
long which means it's held the soil
there and it's kept everything in place
from erosion and wind erosion as well
but there's lots of other benefits as
well one thing we never want to forget
about cover crops is that great root
mass that's under the surface there's a
tremendous amount of biomass here and
not only do we have that biomass that's
creating carbon and everything else
underground it's also creating a
tremendous amount of soil structure
think about all this structure
underneath some of it being brought to
you by the roots alone other some of the
fungi and other things that are growing
on that root and the structure that they
can create and promote that biomass
gives us the ability to to run across
this field without having compaction and
other things like that plus to put a lot
of carbon or organic matter down into
that soil another great part about this
is the reduction of weeds that you're
not going to have near the competition
early spring that you have to deal with
as you would in a fallow or an open
field biological activity is a huge part
of our cover cropping system and as we
keep something live and growing there's
a tremendous amount of biology that
continues late into the fall and early
spring as our soils warm up now again
some folks might think about this and
look at it and say boy it's really time
to go out and determinate that crop but
let's think for a moment that all of the
things that we just mentioned the soil
conservation the organic matter building
all the biological
activity including also that nutrient
retention and release is going to only
be benefited as we allow that cover crop
to grow longer and longer
i always say farmers should always think
about trying to harvest as much sunlight
as possible that's true in our crops and
it's true in our cover crops as well
as we allow this plant to grow
through the process of photosynthesis
that plant is bringing carbon dioxide in
and releasing oxygen
where did that carbon go
it went right into the soil either
through our roots and things like that
or once we do terminate this plant all
the carbon that it has sequestered is
going to turn into organic matter into
that soil
also don't forget when we talk about
organic matter not only is that good for
the soil but it also increases our
nutrient holding capacity and increases
our water holding capacity over time as
we increase that organic matter in the
soil and that's great for our operation
now another benefit that maybe we don't
always think about but there might even
be potential to gain revenue from this
crop as well for instance if you have
changed a practice you may even be
eligible for corteva's carbon incentive
things like brand new to cover cropping
new to no-till maybe you're trying your
hand with a grass and a legume versus a
straight grass what about allowing that
cover crop to grow longer or maybe even
establishing it earlier in the fall
if you have anything like that going on
on your farm you may want to talk with
your granular digital business manager
for more information
another big thing i'm talking to guys
about this year that's a huge benefit to
allowing our cover crop to grow is the
fact that we don't have as much
glyphosate in the marketplace as what we
would like to have
some guys are fairly tight on on their
supplies and we know some of these cover
crops can be fairly hard to to terminate
so what would it look like to instead of
burning it down now and then coming back
and maybe needing another application uh
closer to planting or post-planting what
about just going in and planting green
and then applying
now that brings me to this whole idea of
planting green that's going to be what
this field has done but i'll throw a few
cautions out for you just in case you're
thinking about this and are new to it
first off
typically when we think about planting
green thick stands are not the best for
us for that planting
anything around a bushel of rye and as
you get above that a bushel of rye is
great as you get above that you're
probably going to get so thick if you
let your cover get really large that it
may be a challenge to get planted into
and have that seed slot closed correctly
the other thing is is not all planters
are
created equal whenever you think about
planting green make sure that your
planter is set up in a sense that you
can go in and make sure that you get a
good planting in that
if you're unsure there's lots of folks
that have been in and doing this for a
good while go ahead and reach out to one
of them and talk with them a little bit
the other thing i always tell with guys
is to always think about starting with
small changes if you're new to cover
cropping think about planting early
or maybe terminating early or at least
only play with planting green on some of
those early planted acres where your
cover crop is not going to be nearly as
big
now one thing that i'm going to do is
we're going to return to this operation
probably even this field
throughout the planting and growing
season and we're going to watch some of
this in action so stay tuned
now if you want more information about
this don't hesitate to reach out to your
pioneer sales rep agronomist or other
employee for more information about the
carbon incentive that i talked about
talk with your local granule granular
digital business manager
thanks for your time and attention and i
hope you found this video informative
and helpful i wish you the best this
spring as we prepare for 2022 to manage
and get the most out of your pioneer
products thanks again
that concludes this pioneer agronomy
video podcast visit our page on
pioneer.com and follow us on twitter and
facebook for more agronomy insights
you